- YEAH!
ALL RIGHT, MAN.
I THINK THAT'S KARL.
HE'S BRINGING US
SOME PARTY SUPPLIES
FOR THE FESTIV-LAY.
- YES!
- WAY COOL.
- WHOO!
- ENERGY.
[both convulsing]
- WHAT IS THAT?
- IT'S AN ENERGY THING.
- OH, THAT'S MORE ENERGY.
- YES, ENERGY.
- IT'S A TOTAL
ENERGY THING, MAN.
- COOL.
- WHAT'S UP, DUKE?
- EW, YOU SMELL.
- THANK YOU.
- HEY, MAN, WHERE'S
YOUR EX-GIRLFRIEND?
MOLLY?
- WHAT? NO.
I DON'T KNOW A MOLLY.
- I THINK HE'S TALKING
ABOUT MOLLY, THE DRUG.
IT'S LIKE ECSTASY,
BUT--BUT IT'S, LIKE,
DIFFERENT SOMEHOW,
NO ONE KNOWS.
- NO, I THINK I KNOW BLAKE
A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THAN YOU, ADAM,
AND I THINK HE'S TALKING
ABOUT A CHICK NAMED MOLLY,
RIGHT?
- OH, NO, I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE DRUG.
I WANT DRUGS.
GIVE 'EM TO ME.
THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE HERE FOR, BUD.
- YEAH, OF COURSE
I HAVE THAT MOLLY.
RIGHT HERE, MAN.
- ALL RIGHT. GIMME, GIMME.
- SO YOU'RE GOING
TO A RAVE, HUH?
- YOU CANNOT JOIN US,
THOUGH.
- ALL RIGHT, LOOK, IF YOU
WANT THE MOLLY, OKAY,
THEN YOU NEED TO CHANT
THE RAVER'S PRAYER WITH ME.
OKAY, READY?
AND HERE WE GO.
WE ARE ONE MASSIVE
TRIBAL VILLAGE--
SAY IT WITH ME.
THAT TRANSCENDS MANMADE LAW--
- DUDE, COME ON.
- CAN I JUST, UM--
CAN I JUST GET THE STUFF?
I'LL GIVE YOU
THIS POPSICLE, MAN.
YOUR--YOUR DEAD EYE HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT IT THE WHOLE TIME.
- YEAH, I FEEL--I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S A GOOD DEAL.
- YEAH, ALL RIGHT. COOL.
- THERE YOU GO.
LET ME GET THAT.
- AND THERE YOU GO.
COME ON.
LA-LA-LA-LA-LA-LA-LA!
THERE YOU GO,
YOU DIRTY BITCH.